this is the most unique child I know she
was a bit like an elastic band she could
never sit still she was always on the go
she has always had her friends or out
the family or or simply just in a club
she did so many different activities in
fact in her in her life she actually
quite lots of things that perhaps others
having it done
she was always for the smiles whirling
around the hurricane she'd scoot the
boys up and kiss them till they cried
and squeeze them and always come in
through the door and joke about how she
was late and it was because she was
talking to somebody where she had to
help somebody do something there was
never a time where she would say I can't
or I won't I'm too busy
no matter what she was doing she would
make time you it's just complete
disbelief as much as you're listening to
what they're saying none of it is going
you're not it's not happy it can't be
until I'd seen her as much as I was
saying we you know we're very certain it
is know until I've seen her it still
could be chance even though there wasn't
a chance really but it's like a complete
emptiness just overcoming it all at once
the whole world falling apart but lasts
everything else is going on around you
you're just in this very small bubble of
everybody telling you exactly how you're
meant to be feeling what you're meant to
be doing and it's so far from that
people can pick up text books they can
read them into their blue in the face it
is not as it is written it is such a
more complex layer of sorrow and
heartache and
just destruction
to think but you wake up and you start
each day and everything's been fine and
not even 12 hours later your worlds and
pieces and then you have to think I have
other children I have to have to try and
explain this to them because everybody's
so different every child's so different
each of them then had to have it
explained in a different way what you
want to fall apart and and you just you
can't because you have to explain it
before somebody else does
I know you have to help them
so really you don't have a choice you
have to survive you either and allow it
to destroy you will you fight I'll fight
I won't let Lucy's memories die I won't
let her be forgotten I won't let this
destroy any more people than what has
already the biggest person the biggest
smiling person in our lives that's been
taken and she's never gonna come back
I'm sitting there and hoping and
thinking should just come back and say
holy a stupid you know I'm just lay or
ash that nanny's or a friend no she's
not she's not here
I won't let whoever has done this
destroy anybody else destruction has
been caused its destruction enough my
little girl was the biggest destruction
that could have been caused within this
already no one else should crumble
that's why I stayed as a half it doesn't
mean I don't go sit and cry and I don't
sit and thinking and have things to deal
with myself
even if I'm out and people see me and
I'm not always crying that doesn't mean
I'm not upset it doesn't mean I've
forgotten she won't be forgotten it just
means I have to be strong for myself and
for everybody else then we travel to go
and see DC and it was horrible probably
never wish it upon anybody
certainly not something he ever has bet
to happen he ever aspired to be
welcoming one life into the world
and then happy to lay another to rest
should never happen my thumb Lucy should
still be here the day is imagined to one
the hours seemed as it came really
quickly
and then other times they seemed as
though they're not most days if you ask
me what day of the week it was I really
couldn't even tell you it's just a
complete whirlwind of everything going
on but whilst still just feeling as
though you're just at the beginning
still so it's still exactly the same day
the first day that you're told
but it's not I think for everybody to
work together and keep Lucy's memories
alive first yeah yearly to to keep
fundraising for the causes very much a
needed there is a big bigger project was
currently being discussed which would
give back to the community as a whole
every day of every week of every hour
keeping people safe and giving them
things to do
you should never plan for tomorrow as to
what you can do today because tomorrow
might not come just as Lucy found all
the plans that she had all the things
that she wanted to do she now County